il y a longtemps qu'on avait vu le
premier ministre marché paisiblement
devant le parlement et les camions ont
beau avoir été chassés du centre-ville
d'ottawa justin trudeau crois que la loi
sur les mesures d'urgence est toujours
nécessaire ces jours ci dans le moment
présent
la situation est encore fragile
la situation d'urgence est encore
présente présente selon lui parce qu'il
ya des menaces de récidive les
manifestants se trouvent encore dans la
région de tahoua les postes frontaliers
pourrait de nouveau être ciblés nous
allons continuer de surveiller au jour
le jour pour voir quand est-ce qu'on
pourra le lever ce serait pas pour
l'immédiat monsieur maurice à la tête
d'un gouvernement minoritaire les
libéraux ont pu bénéficier de l'appui du
npd même si le chef avoue l'avoir fait à
reculons notre décision était basée
vraiment sur la menace notre appui
continu d'être réticents parce que on
pense qu'on n'aurait dû jamais être dans
cette situation
les conservateurs avaient déjà indiqué
qu'ils voteraient contre la loi qu'il
n'estime pas nécessaire
est ce que on devait avoir besoin de
cette fois là pour que les policiers
fassent le travail qu'ils ont fait on ne
croit pas 0 camions et 0 manifestants un
point de vue partagé par les bloquistes
pour eux utiliser la loi de façon
préventive et abusif des usines de
camionneurs qui ont quitté ottawa ont
menacé que dès que ce sera possible
ils vont revenir alors combien temps
premier ministre veut maintenir les
mesures d'urgence ce pôle est en vigueur
pour l'éternité que ceux qui appuient un
bon joueur veuille bien se leurrer
même si tous les députés libéraux ont
voté en faveur de la motion certains
comme le québécois joël live band ont
quand même exprimé certaines réserves je
me demande si elle est toujours
nécessaire dans les circonstances
les deux élus ont choisi de se ranger
derrière le premier ministre parce
qu'ils estiment qu'il s'agit d'une
question de confiance etc ce n'est pas
le moment d'aller en élections
après les députés aux communes ce sera
maintenant au sénat de se prononcer plus
tard cette semaine et ce n'est pas clair
encore si une majorité approuve le
recours à la loi sur les mesures
d'urgence
mais un rejet de la chambre haute
pourrait créer des remous car les
sénateurs ne sont pas des représentants
élus et si leur ans partait radio canada
ottawa